this is the theme the biju bismillah al
hamdulillah assalamu alaikum peace be
with you thank you for tuning in to
another episode of the Dean show we're
here every week trying to help you
understand the most misunderstood way of
life in the world today Islam yet is the
fastest-growing way of life in the world
this is a fact and we cover serious
topics this is a serious show and thank
you for tuning in to the Dean show so
when I come back we're going to talk
about modesty shyness many of us have
gone away from this nature to be shy you
go to the supermarket the billboards
half-naked women all over there you look
at Beyonce Britney Spears just full
naked and then the young ones are
emulating the older ones and next thing
you know you're buying your six-year-old
seven-year-old daughter clothes that
match them and you're forgetting about
shyness and modesty and that is what
we're going to be discussing today with
my next guess that's right he's back
here on adding so shake came out mackay
we'll be right back in the Dijon this is
the team
this is the things is the danger
this is the thing you know this is the
thing is is that angel this is the theme
sour lake o mine instead on earth Allah
peace be with you Zach lahaye like
Salaam now look check this out check
this out look we cater to a lot of not
yet Muslims now they see this on your
head and they wonder is he one of those
guys is he one of the people that are
trying to bring harm to us is he one of
those from al-qaeda is he one of these
people 911 and they're getting freaked
out so we want the truth to be able to
penetrate but want to leave e8a swage
any fears what's going on shape you know
what it's just it's more cultural and
traditional it's not really religious
you're not in a gang no no not really if
I were I'll be the gang leader though
but you don't tell you something a lot
of times even with Muslims in the West
they think like what I'm wearing now
it's like the Islamic garment it's not
it's just a cultural garment and that's
why a lot of times I wear a suit and tie
like you're doing or wear jeans and a
shirt and people be like oh you're not
dressed Islamic Lee well that isn't
Islamic anyways but people associate it
with being Islamic and sometimes when
you give a lecture you put it on because
people expect that of you but not
because it's really an Islamic a tire or
anything like that some people you go to
certain places and if you don't look
like them you don't dress like them you
don't sound like them we don't want them
moslems over here so they see you and it
sounds like the same people who are
telling certain people to get to the
back of the bus the same kind of racism
do you feel that this is kind of the
same thing we're talking about well it
certainly sounds the same different
style but it's my same thing happening
yeah and you know it's interesting that
for our history in the United States
there's always a group that's that
suppressed you know and you know first
it was the Native Americans then it
became the during the world wars you
know the Japanese Japanese and it became
that and maybe it still is the African
Americans one actually one
african-american civil rights leader he
said that you know the Muslim is a new
Negro yo shimmy yeah so you're actually
Negro down a few so we they went from
now you hatin on the Japanese you hating
on the Native American hating on the
african-american but now you hate not
all of them because a Muslim is one who
acquires peas by submitting to the owner
of peace and Muslims are white black
yellow or they of all the above yeah but
this hatreds got to stop doesn't it
needs to stop and this isn't this isn't
the way and this isn't why a lot of the
the immigrants that came to America they
came under the pizza you know and
thinking that that wouldn't exist in
america so it's unamerican if I can if I
could say that you know and even though
before we get to our main topic even
those who have this this hatred this
racism I have trust that they can change
because if some of the harshest enemies
of Islam back then and simply Islam
means to acquire peace by submitting to
the one guy right this is what it means
so even those opponents of Islam way
back then they accepted Islam when they
just got to open their heart and mind
and we're exposed to it right I mean I
don't want to repeat jokes on your show
but I think I said this before we sell
it again when it was Halloween and when
I was friday and i was going to friday
prayer which is around noon so I was
dressed like this and this old lady's
walking her dog and she saw me and she
said oh you're starting early so he
thought this is my halloween costume you
know I'm sure now they're laughing and
you know what someone even the the
biggest haters got a smile on his face
absolutely so we kind of you know
melting his heart but if I might say
mashallah you look very nice there thank
you you can't see it but I see it
there's newer coming like coming out on
family trying to keep up with you that's
how much a lot so let's start now let's
do it you go into the supermarket and
bam it's in your face right BAM it's
over here you turn over here stock for
the law you got to turn man you can't
look nowhere it seems like more and more
people are going away from shyness from
modesty it's not the cool thing you got
to show more rather than less what is
going on excellent you know let's first
define it right so modesty in Arabic is
higher right and the word higher in
Arabic it's actually a little bit more
than modesty it's it has bashfulness in
it has modesty in it and it also has in
it self respect if you respect yourself
and you don't want to humiliate yourself
in front of Allah in front of other
people and in front of yourself then
you'll have this type of higher self
respect humility yes absolutely so it's
a mixture of all these things put
together
and you know very very useful all of
them all valuable meanings so the the
thing is that yes everyone's supposed to
have modesty but I'll tell you even now
amongst Muslims they see that if you're
modest that you're not what are the
words they use that you're not you know
you know I'm like in your face you're
not you know you don't take control of
things you know you don't take the
initiative because of this guy has
modesty yeah so people confuse it with
having weak personality and the confuser
with a lot of things that I hope for
Charla in this episode we can clear some
of that fog and shop now how do we get
people to realize that you know showing
less is better than showing more and it
starts at an early age in elementary
schools out of the public schools you
know what if you're not it seems like
it's not cool if you're showing more you
got you know this out here and that out
there then you know what now you're
getting the boys attention and now like
the one who's not showing she's mad as
she shot she's not getting the attention
so now you know we fall into the trap
but what is Islam what is the way of God
what is this this is what God wants for
for you to just be just selling out and
showing everything out there for just a
dollar for the money absolutely not and
you know this is one of the problems
right first of all when this is one of
the things that psychologists say about
it even non-muslims they're saying that
when a woman is taught that her value is
related to her sexuality then she does
everything to promote her sexuality to
dress seductively to accidentally to be
promiscuous because he learned that
that's her value in society and this is
what women learn now you know they dress
skimpily so that men can appreciate them
and you know whistle at them and harass
them in that way and you know in
magazines they want to sell a movie you
put a scene in it with a woman you want
to sell a magazine you put a woman on
the cover even things they're totally
unrelated you put a woman in the
commercial to sell it so then the woman
has come down to a level of being a
commodity pushing device more or object
more so than you know have a human being
with value one of the interesting things
and you'll see and your viewers will see
how this is so true we know if a woman
enters a room if it's a board meeting
whatever it is a chest do presentation
and she enters in with you know scantily
clad and she's showing
her body parts the men in the room will
never appreciate her intelligence first
she will walk in as an object she's not
gonna walk in there going to say oh she
looks intelligent they're gonna look at
her as a sexual object and then maybe if
she's smart she can impress them and
they'll think of what she's also smart
but first they only see her as an object
and this is one of the problems you'll
find that in the West a lot of times men
can like the society cannot take a woman
who is effeminate as a leader they
cannot accept her as a leader and if you
look at it most of the times the leaders
the female leaders in the West are very
androgynous is the word they they use
because it means that they have male
characteristics like they wear either
these suits in other female suit I don't
know what they call it yes they have
short hair styles and the list I mean
Margaret Thatcher in the UK short hair
stoic as they described her not me yes
Hillary Clinton short hair again they
describe her as in a cold and stoic
condoleezza rice rice against short
hairs a pattern here Janet Reno if you
recall it Saturday Night Live these to
constantly make fun of her as a man
Janet Reno's a man constantly what
they're doing yeah because they can only
they can accept an effeminate women in a
leadership position because to them it
has been trained with movies and
magazines she's just a sexual sexual
object but when a woman you know looks
more masculine not my words again then
they can accept her because they
feminine woman is just an object so the
woman has become nothing but an object
now and that's why the subject of higher
is so much more important now we know
that Islam which cause a person to
acquire peace and I keep saying this
because a lot of times many of the
viewers have heard it but there's a good
chance and I know that there's thousands
of new not yet Muslims that Thun on they
hear this Arabic word what's this all
about this is some new religion now this
is the same way of life that was lived
by all and taught by all the messengers
of God submit to the One God your will
to his will so along with that call then
the development of your character being
the best human being that you can be and
now this we're talking about today that
shine is that modesty that is escaping
us right how do we get it back well
that's the that's the
question of the day right how do you get
it back and of course the good thing is
you can get it back because if you
couldn't get it back Allah wouldn't
commanded of you yes i have hiya you
know a number of things and so many
excellent examples you know they
describe the Providence island because
now even Muslim men think hires only for
the woman yeah I don't have to have hyah
I don't have to be modest and shy and
bashful and humble and you know so what
they describe the process seldom that he
was the most modest amongst us and he
was more shy more bashful than a virgin
girl on the first night of her wedding I
mean you can imagine how this
description how she would be so bashful
the Priscilla more bashful than her and
this is a man and a leader and the
general and in the courageous man but
still he had this quality and then the
rest of the narration says that and if
he disliked something we could see it
immediately in his face so it's not just
for women men also are supposed to have
higher meaning they're supposed to be
shy or have modesty be bashful as well
you know and have the self respect so
it's not just for the women something
that's a quality of a believer so we're
going to take a break and we'll be back
with more with [ __ ] came out a mech e
here on a Dean shell I am not afraid to
stand alone if a box by my side I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stand alone if Eliza
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone good for lives by
my side I am not afraid to stand
the Quran says don't kill women don't
don't kill the old people don't attack
the civilians this is what the Prophet
Muhammad told us it will fail you know
gossip that the Prophet SAW solid never
ever stopped a war against anybody so if
you find yourself your Iman is going
down check yourself there is none woody
to be worship except Allah alone you got
some serious of music in the car bobbing
your head to 50 Cent's oh no it's common
sense don't do things that can hurt
people Lady Gaga googoo and all that
other nonsense blue Inga's head on back
fighting slander Lee and such substances
that smoking state route 18 inch biceps
we'll see what happens to Eddie on the
deed show and we hold it down on a game
show early make sure y'all tune back
here on the Dean show with [ __ ] came out
and mekhi thank you for trying at a time
it's always always a pleasure to have
you on the Dean show well you know it's
my pleasure and I'm I'm always here for
one thing and one thing only right and
that's to hold it down on the Dean show
early art that were that was one of our
guests absolutely brother that brother
also like many of them we've had
Napoleon from the outlaws Tupac screw
former crew Elune and then from jay z's
out these people are coming to islam
they're coming to the realization that
you know what all this money and glamour
and glitz is not where it's at Absalom
is where it's at it's cool to be a
Muslim doing all the good at the craters
toilet called us to do it's the new
block so tell us now tell us now tell us
now look at his limited okay we're going
to start and give some practical
examples of the shyness let's say for
the man you know you go into from a
young aide they try to throw all them in
together and a showering naked you know
or you just use shirt off and you flex
in here and every your neighbor
everything is showing so now you grow up
in a culture that's doing that all right
where what is Islam call you to do and
now the person that's listening is going
to be like you know what that makes more
sense right
and and just what kind of we touched on
earlier that when you have higher when
you have modesty and shyness and
bashfulness it's not that you now have a
weak personality or that you're scared
of people or that you not courageous
enough and where you're not
confrontational it's actually because
people miss they confuse it with and I
don't think you're weak because last
time you talking about 500 on the bench
oh that's easy that's nothing so so so
the idea is this that the profits of a
lot of Salem told us in a hadith he said
L hiya Leah Thiele be here basically it
means that nothing except good comes out
of modesty yes no bad comes out of it
whatsoever only good comes out of it so
if you think that you know hiya means
you'll get your rights trampled upon
people will push you around your miskin
you're confusing what hiya is that's not
what hat I asked to have modesty to have
bashfulness and that's why we always
tell sisters you know you're supposed to
have higher right and then they tell you
things like why should I be afraid of
the man you know you know he looks at me
in the eye and I supposed to lower my
gaze I'll stare him down you know if he
wants to fight with me I'll fight back
he wants to exchange bad words yeah
that's not high what we're saying we're
not saying let your rights be trampled
upon we're saying don't lose your hiya
in the process of regaining your rights
yes which is how it's supposed to be one
of the fantastic examples is that of
eyeshadow de la and I the wife of the
prophet saw said them so the problem
when he passed away he was buried in
what they call her apartment or her room
then the first his successor the first
Khalifa Calif Abu Bakr passed away and
he was buried in her room as well so she
narrates she said I used to be you know
relaxed about what I wear because I
would say it's my husband and my father
were buried in there so I wouldn't have
to wear the hijab things like that as I
entered in the room she said then when
Omar alone I know the successor of the
successor when he was buried this one
the Companions now so they know the
right and this was the second Calif in
Islamic history can you compare the like
president yeah exactly like the leader
leader so then when when he passed away
and he was buried in her room she said I
could not come in uncovered she had she
said I would cover up properly out of
hiya from a machinist can you imagine
that out of shyness from a dead person
who is buried underground
but yet this is the kind of higher that
she had this is the mother of the
believers I show the role model for the
Muslim woman now of course people who
don't have higher will see this as well
that doesn't make any sense but for
those who have higher it makes perfect
sense now look look if you're in a
situation a Muslim man and will go to
the woman the Muslim man now you know
sometimes you know awkward situation and
say you're at the gym and you know you
turn around and it's just normal the
person just be BAM just everything's out
there a Muslim he hides his privates
hides his his private areas to explain
this how should a prick like you go and
running for instance as part of shine is
what should you be covering you know
these show your thighs and your no ain't
no speedos and you know run-in and I
gotta talk to us excellent well for the
man it's for him to cover from his navel
all the way up to his knees no one needs
to see the privates examine your wife
exactly absolutely and no one of the
things is that people argue things they
say things like well it's natural for
you to be uncovered because you were
born uncovered you were born naked you
say so what's the problem what we say to
that is that there's actually a very
strong link between you're a man which
is your belief in Allah as Odette and
your your higher your modesty and your
bashfulness and if you if someone were
not that I recommend this but if someone
were to interview people at let's say a
nudist camp you will find that most of
them probably don't have much a man
anyways or don't have belief in Allah or
they're probably atheist or something of
that sort yeah so the true relationship
is that what is natural is for the human
being to cover the private part not to
uncover because if we go back to the
story of Adam and Eve the first thing
they did when they discover that they
were uh Natalie the first man at first
woman yes great example when they sinned
then they realize that they were naked
yeah the first thing the first action
that they did after discovering they
were naked was to try to cover they try
to cover the nakedness right great exact
is so that means the natural thing is to
cover your private parts not to uncover
them yeah as I wanna argue kids were
born next what do you want them to be
born in suits and ties and stuff came
out of the facade to your exhaust suit
he'll cry heal spell out the way he
cries waa okay does it work it doesn't
work like that so the thing is that the
more natural thing is to cover it
interesting just to throw this in the
word Allah which is the word for a
private part in Arabic it actually means
something that's shameful so it's
natural to cover it up you know even
little children if you sometimes you
know if they're 45 years old you're
uncovered in listen no no you know
people will see me because it's natural
to want to cover the private part not to
uncover which is basically when you know
kind of the calls that we've started
hearing after the sexual revolution in
the late 60s and early 70s after that
people started to call to that and and
equate that with liberation so if you're
covered your oppressed dislike how they
assume Muslim women because they're
covered they're oppressed by men and
that's why they're covered but if you're
uncovered you liberate it and you end up
some problems very clear problems with
that argument right color because that
means if you're wearing any amount of
clothing even if it's very skimpy you
still not fully liberated so the argue
with argument would be one that you
fully liberate yourself you know there
was actually one time a speaker who's
giving a lecture and then a non-muslim
woman came in and she started pointing
it though and the Muslim woman that were
covered and she was yelling at the
speaker why are they covered like that
assuming you're oppressing them that's
why they're covered yeah so he said well
you were born naked were you clothes
right now Wow and she said modesty and
she just chose the right word yeah she
said modesty he said well modesty more
modesty modesty more modestly that's the
argument that just goes with nature man
I mean if you're covered because of
modesty if that means if they're covered
more it's more modesty yes and
uncovering doesn't mean liberation no it
just means lack of modesty that's all it
means I really think you know because we
have the chief deceiver and people
forget I mean that you have this devil
and the satanic forces and he's pimping
people that he's working day and night
to pimp the man to pimp the woman and by
going away from the guidance of the
crater he's pimping you take it off take
it all off absolutely yes and now you
just become a commodity you're just a
toy for the man exactly isn't it so true
it's very truthful and it is getting
worse and worse every time you know in
the 1920s in America if a woman were
wore pants that was there was an uproar
was they weren't even allowed to
actually so but then you know the
standards become worse and worse
and worse and worse the more you go back
isn't it they wouldn't show a lot of
things that are unsigned the TV you know
right acuity all the just horrific
things that you see you go back you know
women they have to cover their arms and
the law skirts this is in America but
I'll tell you something interesting like
like early in the 50s and 60s even
before that the argument but the
Liberals were making is that you know
people will will fornicate and commit
zina and and do wicked deeds so long as
you forbid them from it so they're using
the forbidden fruit argument as long as
you forbid people they're going to do
that but if you allow it people are
going to take it easy and they're just
going to leave it and so the
conservatives today they argue they say
look now things have gotten worse you
said if we allow people to do what they
want to do it's going to get people are
going to take it you know easy and just
forget about it so I'm going to become
in the forefront of their mind but the
opposite has happened now because people
allowed a little bit of promiscuity they
allow someone to show this much of this
their hand and then that much of their
like it got worse today the standards
have become a lot worse so it's the
opposite of the forbidden fruit argument
which they also use for example they
tell you in in Sweden the teenage
pregnancy rate is much lower than in the
United States right and they say because
in at an early age they teach the kids
in school about contraceptives and this
and that and so on and that's why we
should do the same thing in America
because you know there's some stigma and
they don't discuss it openly and so
therefore people do it and then they
have teenage pregnancies that kind of
solution is not acceptable in Islam
because in the end you still have youth
committing zina yeah sin is not
acceptable it's not about whether or not
they use you know protection or concert
contraceptives it's about the act of
xena fornication occasion so it's not
acceptable so this is some of the
problems you know people try to make
arguments like that but they don't work
let's uh we're going to take a break
their signal we got to go for break
we'll be right back with more on the
Dean show one God wish him alone do what
he wants you to do put your desire is
this thing inside you that just wants
this and why's that and you just can't
get enough you know what you'll never
get enough until the dirts in your mouth
don't let it come to that be sincere and
honest
as the one who created you to guide race
the first step put off chasing all the
women and the good times and the parties
and this and that there is no one would
be a voice it except a lot don't wait
you never know is that would come today
for you back here on the Dean show and
again we are really stressing that this
way of life Islam calls to everything
good and a sincere person who's not
wanting to follow their lusts and
desires I don't think anyone the father
that's looking at his daughter he don't
want no googly eyed man all over his
daughter and trying to molest her with
his eyes and you want to protect was so
precious to you you don't like people
touching your car but now that girl goes
out and what's the first thing on the
mind of the man right that's how it is
but now what's Islam saying protect the
most valuable things are women can you
elaborate again I mean just this is the
rationale and talk about please how we
worry about our money and our cars and
all these things about how Islam right
it really puts the women to such a high
level of this way that would really like
protect it from all this evil and I
think you said it best anything that's
valuable you protect it and you cover it
yes you typically cover the valuable
thing right so if you know even women
their most valuable jewelry item it's
covered they don't put it out in the
dining table you know or you know on the
dashboard of the car it's covered it's
protected and anything that's due to you
cover and you protect it and so you know
the chastity the modesty that all these
things the beauty of the woman it's
supposed to be protected therefore it's
supposed to be covered when it's not
covered many bad things happen in
society the way men look at women and
this is something that has happened now
in north america and i don't know how
many if we were to reverse it it would
take decades to transfer this image of
how women have become in the minds of
men they've just become like targets you
know yeah and they talk about them also
like items like objects not as human
beings and that's why you know to show
the importance of higher and in the
profits of salem he
described that Iman belief and owned and
in Allah has 70 odd branches many
branches the highest of which is to say
that I had a lot that no God is worthy
of worship except Allah alone the lowest
level is to remove an obstacle or an
obstruction from the road so then but
notice he said there are 70 odd branches
of a man then he gives only one yeah of
a translator faith or faith or belief
right then he gives only one example and
he said well hiya bill dominant eamon
and modesty is one of the branches of a
man so very quickly the scholars say why
did he only give that one example they
say because if you have this one
characteristic modesty you will get
everything else so our sisters and
humanity our sisters in Islam this goes
back again to shyness coming back to
shyness and then naturally you're going
to want to observe the hijab and you're
going to want to implement all the good
that the creator's told us to do the
complete shyness absolutely and is this
you know for the sisters also we're
having a hard time with the hijab what
advice do you give to them you know the
reminder is that and I know we're
running out of time but one of the
scholars have categorized modesty or
shyness into six different types but one
of the most important ones is having
shyness with Allah subhana Todd you know
people will use bad words in but they're
ashamed to use it in front of an elderly
person but they're not a shame to use in
front of Allah those smoke they aren't
to hide it from the imam or from the
religious leader in the local community
but they don't hide it from Allah you
know a woman will uncover in front of
her father maybe she has another outfit
to make him think she's dressed well but
in front of Allah she's not dressed well
it's for the believing men and women to
constantly remember the fact that allah
so allah is watching and you should be
more shy of allah than you are of other
individuals that you held in high regard
you know and that's why the scholars say
that sometimes the sin you're committing
or the fact that you don't care that
allah sees you're committing a sin can
be worse than the sin itself that you're
committing that's deep that's deep last
minute last minute so just some some
some examples now shyness and the way
you speak not using curse words saying
good things what I was dressing properly
talking properly acting properly
what is it in dealings with you in
everything in business dealings and
shading yeah because some people tell
you know you know you've heard the
saying businesses business meaning
business is business I can be cutthroat
I could be rude to you but then after
that we can go get dinner together what
how does it work it doesn't work like
that because your good manners is a
constant it's something that's constant
not something that you do whenever
you're in a good mood or you can turn
off your good manners because we're in a
business meeting no so it's constant so
high and everything in speech in
dealings in dressing in behavior and
walking in everything with your parents
everything gun-shy being modest is what
Islam is calling us to thank you very
much my pleasure idea law reward you
well then go ahead thank you very much
and thank you again again you you've got
to learn something new we always stress
the call to worship just the crater not
his creation character development and
then shyness you got to learn about
shyness is something again that just
goes up here with your nature and
everything if you investigate Islam
you'll see that everything you learn it
just makes sense it's not something
that's weird you're not doing something
that's way out there bizarre something
mr. go and only you know esoteric we're
just a few people understand this Islam
is something that's from the Creator so
it's got to make sense and I'm sure if
you have an open heart an open mind you
know this makes sense so if you like to
learn more call the number on the screen
1 866 to Islam visit us here every week
on the Dean show we also have the new
radio show at the Dean show calm you can
also pick up our new DVDs and share this
message of peace peace acquired by
submitting your will to the will of the
One God Islam we'll see you next time
peace be unto you is the main teen one
of the beautiful things about our
religion of Islam is the emphasis on
direct ritual and prayer whom God
directly there is no intermediary the
lights will go on after the party and
the party will end it's very simple and
very clear there are no superstitious
rituals no strange incantations the time
is running out you might not make it to
tomorrow and this is something that we
need to think
no speech is better than to do that was
call people to Allah and to do the word
no speech is better no nothing is better
than that is it true that if one person
I'm the Allah giving you an ability to
guide so much for the lost permission
the craters permission that was better
than everything in this world but in the
whole world and everything that's in it
in another narration it's better than
the best of wealth but if we really felt
that Eddie would we not be giving out
getting java and this is something that
we encourage all the msas all the dowel
organizations the musjid forget this we
want to create more we give these to the
non mrs. for free for free for free we
want our brothers it eats combed it slay
everybody sleeping i arise and ask a lot
of thinking me omar you see hola you
know all the sins I do I turn to you to
figure my sing tomorrow I'm you see for
slave you don't my love in Lord I'm the
one runs away all the guide me